hallo und herzlich willkommen ihr lieben
mein name ist renée weibel und ich
spiele die giotto in der dritten staffel
der telenovela vier deutsch lernen
also macht euch gefasst auf 33
unglaublich spannende folgen von ich hab
dich so kennen und lieben gelernt und
dichter mit der meisten verletzt
die größte herausforderung bei toto für
mich ist dass der fokus ganz klar auf
der sprache liegt weil das format wurde
erschaffen damit die menschen deutsch
lernen deswegen musste ich mir angewöhnt
sehr deutlich zu sprechen
also was mir hilft mich in die rolle
hinein zu fühlen ist
ich habe auch in migrationshintergrund
ich bin mit 14 nach deutschland gekommen
in der schweiz gross geworden und ich
hab halt gemerkt die sprache ist der
schlüssel zur integration gerade im
teenager-alter wenn man nicht auf waren
und dazu gehören und ein reines
hochdeutsch zu sprechen war mir sehr
wichtig um halt einfach dazu zu gehören
und ich war aufzufallen sehr turbulente
zeiten und ich merke einfach dass ich
zeit brauche um mich an berlin wieder in
ordnung zu bringen
der unterschied zu den üblichen
deutschen serien die im fernsehen laufen
zb verbotene liebe für die ich seit ein
paar jahren auch drehe ist dass man hier
insbesondere noch einmal auf die
grammatik und auf die aussprache achten
muss
du musst nicht gerade ein bisschen was
streichen nachdem und jetzt habe ich das
woanders mal eingebaut
nachdem sie ihm auf die schliche
gekommen war wollte sie selbst ein stück
vom kuchen eiskalt sie war nur aufs geld
aus ich mag eigentlich jede art von
kunst und ich komme aus einer
schauspielerfamilie muss man sagen und
er hat mir noch gefehlt irgendwie die
kunst des schauspiels irgendwie für mich
aus zu erleben und sich der deutschen
männer aus sehr dankbar dass ich das
verbinden kann musik mit schauspiel ist
natürlich für mich ein traum und der
geht erst mal in erfüllung
wir haben zu den beiden ersten staffeln
so viel lob und so viel positives
feedback bekommen dass wir gar keine
andere wahl hatten als eine dritte
staffel zu drehen und was mich besonders
freut ist dass immer mehr lehrer zum
unterricht einsetzen also ich treffe
immer wieder auf lehrer auf events oder
messen die sagen ja wir müssen gem
unterricht zeigen weil unsere schüler
fragen danach die wollen das sehen und
damit macht deutsch lernen den noch viel
mehr spaß
ich finde die dritte staffel ist auch
viel action reicher geworden es geht
alles zackiger schnellere dialoge ist
alles mehr action mehr spannung finde
ich die haben uns schauspielern und dem
regisseur dieses baby gegeben und wir
dürfen uns da eigentlich so ein bisschen
austoben so lange wir deutlich sprechen
und es ist halt sehr schön und ich war
traurig sein wenn es vorbei ist